welcome back and last time we covered my
portfolio from high school all the way
through Art Institute all the way to Art
Center's through college so all of my
educational experience we covered in
part one and you can see how I
transitioned from this person who is
pretty shy pretty sheltered and a little
closed up to somebody who felt very very
confident now entering the work market
so you might be wondering what does this
have to do with you and I wanted to show
you in part one how crappy I was as a
young artist as a young designer who
didn't really know what he wanted I
didn't have a clear plan a clear path to
go to to go to market to start working I
kind of felt my way around and what I
want to show you in this now is showing
my transition from somebody who is very
insecure and quiet and shy to somebody
who is now entering the market very
confident and showing how I navigated
from owning my own business to
freelancing to becoming staff creative
director at a company so I'm hoping that
you can see my massive arc in my career
to show you that I'm not even done yet
I haven't even arrived I'm still a work
in progress and all of this you can see
how its added up how its shaped Who I am
today and where it might take me let's
time travel back to 2007 when I
graduated from Art Center the world was
my oyster and I am ready to go conquer
it so let's look at that time period
then you know as a student at Art Center
while I was in school I was already
getting work what I didn't really get
into is that with the peers around me we
developed a little bit of a collective a
little artists collective so as me Chris
real Jaron hoy Michel Ralph Brendon
Wyeth and Erin Bjork so we had six of us
altogether people that were always
working together in the labs kind of
grinding it out and we started to
collaborate and collaborate and started
doing projects together at one point it
might have been seventh term right
before we graduated and we said hey
why don't we make this into a collective
so we form this collective and we were
looking for a name as I have what if we
call our collective born oh my god I
like that it represents birth it
represents something new something fresh
and I think it just clicked for all of
us so we decided to call our collective
born one of our inspirations at the time
was actually Greg Gunn who also works at
blind Greg Gunn a year before in 2006
had graduated with two of his colleagues
and they've also formed the collective
called three-legged legs right out of
college they started their own company
and they got wrapped as directors and so
that was so inspiring for us because we
thought if they could do it over at Otis
we could do it over here at Art Center
and because we had that rivalry and I
know Chris though when I was taking his
class he would brag about them to our
class at Art Center because they all
three of them were his students so
because there was that example of
somebody else who had done this coming
from just being a student that graduated
to starting their own company it's like
dude we could do this so the kind of
work we were doing at the time was an
extension of what we were doing in
school we just wanted to do more of that
it was this fun mixed media approach of
3d animation 2d animation cel animation
practical effects stop-motion filming
with different film stocks like all of
this stuff was so exciting at the time
and motion design was so right for that
because it allowed for the mix of all
these different mediums we just wanted
to do more of that and we wanted that to
be a staple of our studio we wanted to
be known for that to be able to mix
these things up when we graduated
college and we decided to go all in on
Bourne first thing we did is we cut a
reel and made a website so this was our
reel
so that was our reel intro there it says
Bourne and these are a bunch of mostly
school projects at this point so these
are all the things that we're working on
as a collective but you can see there's
a big mix of 3d stuff 2d animation cel
animation you can see a lot of the
collage
stuff that I was into that Chris reel
was also into made its way in here and
you could see that this is a pretty
fresh and funky style if you look at MTV
and vh1 at the time a lot of it look
like this it had this kind of Flair and
style to it and we wanted to add to the
conversation so this was our reel this
is what we put out there as our breakout
it's like hey we're born and we're here
this is what we do but this is the gig
that we did right after college and this
was for Nissan knows for a concept car
called Pivo and this was the second
iteration of it and this is for the
Japanese the Tokyo audio butter show and
we did this in collaboration with Adam
bloomin who is the director on there and
a couple of our other freelance friends
so we all kind of jumped in on this
collective together and they brought
Bourne on to do a lot of the 3d
animation here there was this project
and it was for this record label was
called des genetics hired us to create
this promo video for their label and the
artists that are on there so our
inspiration was to look at old 80's and
90's cartoons and paint these characters
as if they're heroes so this was super
fun to work on we collaborated with a
director who did all the live-action and
they came to us it's like can you add
the graphics on top of this so that was
super fun that was probably one of the
cooler projects that we had done at the
time so he did stage graphics for
Lincoln Park which was pretty cool this
was directed by Chris reel and we all
did a couple of the shots in here and
it's pretty minimal nothing really fancy
we were just showing off our 3d skills
and this was meant to be a backdrop
behind the band it was for their song in
pieces so the band would be playing in
front of this massive screen and then
these graphics would be playing so all
the stuff the operations part took up so
much of our time and a lot less time was
spent on the creative and we didn't
really realize that running the books
you
no trying to manage clients and manage
projects we were hiring freelancers at
the time luckily there was six of us and
we were kind of sharing the load and
passing responsibilities around to each
other but I felt like a lot of my time
was focused on operations of the
business so learned a lot of things
there was a lot I didn't know but I
wouldn't figure that out until 2008 and
in 2008 something happened the housing
market crashed here in the United States
and that had a ripple effect everyone it
was a Manic Monday in the financial
market so in just six months three of
the five biggest independent firms on
Wall Street have now disappeared it's
definitely a very very difficult time
and it's not gonna get better quickly we
didn't feel it right away but it
eventually got to us so we were coming
from this high of all this work just
dropping in our lap in 2007 things were
amazing we're doing cool work at clients
too all of a sudden 2008 things started
to feel a little grim the phone slowly
stopped ringing less enquiries for work
and all of a sudden the work dried up
and it was a really weird place to be
and then we were scrambling like shoot
how come we're not getting work maybe we
should update our reel let's update our
portfolio because that's gonna fix it it
didn't and we realized everything we
didn't know about running a business
which is how do you market yourself how
do you put yourself out there and then
how do you draw in leads we didn't do
any business development and here we are
we've run our business in the market
crash
and we got punched in the face and we
realize everything we didn't know about
running a business and for me in
particular that was very hard because
there's this expectation of me which I
mentioned in part one that I have to be
the best I have to perform at a certain
level and now the market has humbled us
way down here kind of kicked us in the
butt and showed us everything we didn't
know about running a business it was
very tough but at some point in 2009 we
had a heart-to-heart with each other we
looked at each other and said you know I
know we started out on this journey to
do this one thing but we're barely
paying rent we're barely making any
money here we could be making more money
if we just went elsewhere and I think we
all just knew at that point it's like
it's time it's time to close the doors
it's time to close the doors on this big
dream that we had and the market kicked
our button and we weren't ready for it
so in 2009 we shut the doors and we
decided to go our own ways so at this
point of my life this was a huge failure
but it didn't stop me I'm still alive
I'm still here and I'm flourishing that
wouldn't be my last failure for my life
and if I let that stop me if they let
that stop my career man I don't know
what I would be doing I'd be probably
pretty sad but I share this with you
guys to show you that even from closing
a business even in a down market
you can emerge from that and you can
come out stronger because we're all of
my bones had cracked and may be broken
they got stronger and those are things
that I still carry with me to this day
so for those of you guys who might be
experiencing failure right now
don't worry you'll get through this and
you're gonna learn something from this
whether you fail or you succeed you're
always gonna learn from those moments
and failure is probably the best
teaching tool because it's goes the
deepest it's things the hardest but it
will leave a scar on you that you're
gonna remember for the rest of your life
and that's not always a bad thing it's
just a good reminder of what it's like
when you hit rock bottom what it's like
when the stars don't align and you
aren't lucky when a good decision turns
out with bad results these are all
moments where you could learn from them
and it's humbling and you need these
moments in your life otherwise you won't
be prepared because life only gets
harder and you need to have these
failures to prepare you luckily the
motion design industry didn't completely
crash they all felt hurt but there were
still studios that survived so the first
person I called I picked up the phone
they said hey Chris do you have any
freelance work available luckily he said
yes and I started working immediately
Epling and this began my freelance
career after closing my business
all right so we're moving on to the next
chapter of my life which was in 2009
after I'd closed my business born with
my colleagues I went back to the
freelance world and ice entered in as a
freelance motion designer doing design
style frames and animating on
commercials and at this time I was 24
years of age
and I had just come out of this business
with a lot of stress a lot of this
expectation and disappointment as a
result of that expectation looming over
me and now I'm getting to this point in
my life was like man that was a heavy
weight to carry on my back and I had
just released it so this next part of my
life was all about letting go and
releasing and freelance was the best
part of all of this because now I could
go around Studio to studio work in
different places see different people
start and stop whenever I want and
traveled the world do things on my free
time that my business was previously
occupying and this was for Honda it was
a campaign called happy Honda days they
do this every year and it's just their
holiday campaign so is this fun stop
motion commercial with a bunch of 3d I
was hired on as a compositor and
essentially what I did was take all
these different plates all the CG plates
that were rendered out of Maya
took all the plates that they did on a
live-action shoot and sandwich them all
together and make them look good and
clean and cohesive so that the real
world blended with the 3d world like
this one I did over at Merida or that at
the time they're called motion theory
but it was for target and it was for a
campaign to for parents to read to their
children so there was this live-action
shoot that they had done and I was
working on the team that was doing all
the CG animation inside the book so the
book was tracked and then we created
this 3d world inside of the book so that
was a pretty fun campaign to work on
very challenging and it was nice to work
on a very heavy
Effects project like this because I had
in before I worked on this promo for
United States of Tara
which is a show but a woman who has
multiple personalities this was also
with Tomko here at blind so the concept
in here was this rotating cube where
they filmed all the talent on green
screen and kind of rotated the camera
around them but the idea is that every
facet of this cube that rotates is a
different side of this character since
she has multiple personalities which
shows in the show she shows that she has
multi colors to herself
and that was the concept that we were
playing with here super fun very
challenging just to show this concept
and how to pull this off it wasn't
perfect you can see the Tracking's not
amazing on this thing but it was very
fun to figure out and this was for
Showtime then the last one that I have
here this one is for Discovery Channel
it was for the show worst case scenario
is a promo for it and the whole idea was
it supposed to feel kind of like one of
those guidebooks or if you're a boy
scout or something like that and it
shows you how to this is popular in
fishing guides and all that stuff
supposed to mimic the those types of
guides so we did all the tracking and
animation and design on top of this and
made it feel like these were all
overlays on top of Bear Grylls inside
the worst case scenarios because that
was the whole premise of the show they
put him in the worst case scenario and
then he teaches you how he would survive
in that situation this period I really
reserved for a lot of self-discovery a
lot of figuring out what I wanted out of
a career because I got to explore
different studios and shops and
understand different company cultures
different ways of working and be a part
of some really amazing projects and I
even got the chance to work on one of my
favorite video game series of all times
so I played a very small role I believe
it was in 2010 where I got hired by
studio called Logan there here in LA and
we were working on Metal Gear Solid 4 as
one of my favorite video game franchises
of all time and we worked on the visual
effects on some of the intro sequences
but it was one of those moments where I
was like I got to pause and say wow I am
so privileged that I get to work on this
with all of these talented people around
me on a project and game that I've loved
since I was growing up as a kid I think
one of the key things I can attribute my
success to as a freelancer was while I'm
at work I'm giving a hundred and ten
percent and what I mean by that is that
when I'm there and you have hired me for
that day or for that week or for that
month I'm Yours and I'm totally focused
on getting you what you need and at the
beginning of the day or beginning of the
week director might come up to me and
say hey I'd like you to design these
three frames at the end of that day I
might have five frames because I have
show them here's what you asked me to do
and I explored a little bit more with my
free time here's what you asked for and
then here's some other things I thought
up as a result of that and I was trying
to to show my creativity to show that I
can add more to the conversation and I
did this quite often actually where they
set an expectation and I exceeded it
maybe this is in my nature of just
wanting to do well maybe it's my
competitiveness or maybe it's because I
just got humbled by the market running
my business that crushed me and I felt
like oh my gosh I have to survive so I
have to do a little bit more I have to
do a little bit more so maybe all of
those things in conjunction came out in
my work ethic which was to deliver over
deliver on the things that were asked of
me my initial goals and expectations
after I returned to freelance was just
to explore the world just to let loose
and not feel so committed to stuff and I
started bouncing around to different
Studios working with amazing people but
after a while I think I got a little bit
bored of that started moving
horizontally from place to place just
coming on as a hired gun and I think I
started to stagnate a little bit around
2011 at that point I got a call from
mister
though here a blind and he had offered
me a creative director position I
thought about it for a little ball a
little while and I was considering all
my options because the thing is I was
getting paid very well as a freelancer I
had a very good life as a freelancer so
I really had to consider is this
something that I want is this something
that interests me and after I thought
about my career in this lateral movement
and how much fun and how engaged I was
on these very challenging projects where
they brought me in to lead I thought hmm
there was something in there for me and
there's something that I'm missing from
my freelance career right now I should
invest in that and I think at that point
I decided that I'm tired of moving
horizontally and I'm ready to move up
I'm ready to move up to the next
challenge and that would be the next
chapter in my life where I became the
staff creative director at blind now I
have left the freelance world have gone
staff to become a young creative
director at blind at the age of 26 so I
was going through this big transition
where before I was just a hired gun
project to project either doing the
design and animation or both and blind
at the time had already been testing me
as an art director kind of pushing me to
lead because they could see those
qualities in me and I think Chris was
looking to bring some young blood to the
team to mix things up probably to bring
up a divergent or different way of
thinking here to the studio because he
could see my scrappiness so it was very
interesting because at the time I
thought I was gonna be doing more of the
same I thought I was gonna be doing the
things that I was doing on some of my
freelance projects as an art director
leading the team but it was actually so
much more than that and I wasn't ready
for the next couple of years of my life
as a creative director see the thing is
I was really good at making I was really
good at animating I was really good at
designing at this point and I was really
good at just working with the team just
like being shoulder-to-shoulder and say
alright I
the shot you do this shot will pass this
back and forth so on and so forth the
thing that I didn't realize and the big
gap that I had to fill as a creative
director is you should actually be doing
a lot of managing and this required a
whole lot of soft skills that I didn't
quite have yet and this was the
challenge that I had for the next couple
of years as a young creative director
see the thing is I didn't know how to
talk to clients I didn't know how to
delegate to a team I had a really hard
time figuring out how to articulate what
was in my head to come out as words in
my mouth so that somebody else might
understand and act on that I think it's
really important to be able to
communicate your thoughts because if you
plan to do any kind of job where you're
working with a team you need to be able
to explain to somebody why you're
thinking what you're thinking how they
might get there and what specifically
they might be able to do so that they
can take action I think most creative
people like to use these fun big buzz
words like exciting and rad and cool but
those don't really mean anything if the
person on the other side doesn't know
what you're talking about if they have
their own interpretation of the word so
you need to be able to clearly define a
goal a set of parameters for that person
to work within so that at the end of the
day or the end of the week you have
something that's usable that's something
that is addressing the challenge of the
projects for the clients so all you
creative people out there I know we're
very good at doing this learning how to
use the tools and techniques but I
encourage all of you to read and write
and practice articulating your thoughts
because the more you do that the more
powerful you become as a communicator
and that's basically what we do if you
take away anything from all of my
portfolio is design is communication and
while my early years as a creative
director here at blind weren't that
successful luckily I had the space to
fail luckily I had these opportunities
where I quickly wanted to course-correct
them because I was very mindful of them
I wasn't
ignoring my shortcomings I was looking
at them as a real thing as something
that I was lacking in something that I
needed to develop and I think this is
something that I've realized looking
back is that every time I saw a gap in
front of me between who I am and who I
need to be or want to be I saw that as
opportunity not as something that is
getting in my way and if anything I want
to give you guys that advices that look
at those big gaps in front of you
between your skill level now and where
you want to be or the job that you
currently have and where you want to be
as an opportunity as something to close
and capture because it's there for you
if you want to get it and I feel like
I've experienced that through many
cycles of my life even here now as a
creative director okay so one of the
first projects that I got to do as a
creative director I think it was in the
winter of 2012 I believe it was for this
company called finish and they're a
dishwashing detergent and the agency had
come to us with us ideas like well we
want to make this thing where it's like
an enchanted forest and our magical
product flies through the forest that's
filled with dishes and it cleans
everything that makes everything
spotless the next project
was probably my favorite project of this
time and it was I remember we got called
up on a Thursday night and the client
was asking hey do you think you can send
us a treatment for this video game
project by Monday does that mean they
want us to work the weekend I don't know
not signing up for a weekend work but
whatever and they told us it all is for
a big prominent video game and all we
can tell you is that it's about witches
I was the only one out of all the
creative directors that wanted to pitch
on this thing I think everybody else is
like now that sounds so speculative that
sounds so fishy but I need stuff to do
like I hate to practice I just need to
practice as a creative director
so I said sure you know what I pitch
well let me toss in my hat
so we signed our NDA's we signed out the
paperwork
and they gave us more information they
said this game is written by JK Rowling
and it takes place in the world of Harry
Potter I was like oh snap they're like I
love the Harry Potter movies I love that
universe and I was like what the heck
this is so cool and I said also this
game is unique one of its kind because
we're launching new technology on the
Sony Playstation and it's called the
wonder book and the wonder book is a our
technology and you guys are going to be
designing the animated sequences that
would end every chapter of this game I
was like what are you kidding me
so this is the wonder book this is for
the PlayStation 3 and it was this
peripheral which was blue and it had all
these tracking markers on it and this is
what you would see as the gamer so this
is actually what the game looks like so
everything would be tracked on there and
you have this wand and you can see in
your view all these things are tracked
to it so I was very early a our
technology it was super cool so
innovative at the time and then where
our stuff took place was in between each
chapter after you finish a chapter this
moment would happen where this now gets
projected out of the book and then you
would see our animation there and then
I'll show you a cut down of the work we
did so we ended up doing five conundrums
all together in one intro animation so
as a total of six animation which took
us about seven months to complete so in
that seven months we had closed off a
part of the office because we had to
keep it secret from everybody else
well so here's some of the process work
we built some of it in 3d some of it in
2d this was our shot list so here are
the storyboards so all of us all of my
team my interns my designers we would
all sketch out
and I said you know what here's each
line sketch out any ideas that pop out
as we're going through these sequences
so everybody contributed a bunch of
these ideas using post-it notes so we're
just kind of going through them and
playing puzzle trying to see which ideas
link up best which one have cool moments
of transitions and then the team would
build off of that here's the original
illustrations and you can see this is
what those storyboards ended up looking
like each conundrum would teach you
where some wizards or witches had fallen
short because they were arrogant or
impatient or entitled or whatever it was
and the whole point was to teach you as
a young wizard or witch you should not
fall to the same problems that they did
and you should you should become better
than than them that is the early days of
me being a creative director at blind
now that I have spent a couple of years
as a creative director here at blind I
started to reach a full stride where I
became very confident in my
communication skills and my ability to
pitch and win work and all of the stuff
that I was worried about in the earlier
part of my career as a creative director
that was off of my shoulders the weight
of having to know what to say and to
sound intelligent and how to speak to
clients and to people all that stuff was
behind me now I felt fully confident and
that was out of my way and the next
couple of years
starting from around 2014 and on I
really got to focus on my craft on my
skills and pushing the work that I was
doing to the next level so I wanted to
share just a few pieces that I'm very
proud of in this period of my life so it
now it's 2014 now comes along this
opportunity where we had some ties to
the band Coldplay we had a connection
over there and we knew as a group as a
company that we wanted to do a marketing
piece meaning something that is highly
visible with a big artist and we usually
did this about one
a year where we're taking on a project
that we knew is going to be an
investment for us of time and energy not
necessarily a profit maker but something
that will be a marketing piece that will
be a calling card for the company and
we've done this over and over again back
in 2006 and 7 it was the music videos
for Gnarls Barkley and we did the crazy
video in 2007 it was the Justin
Timberlake video loved stoned
we're always highly visible got a lot of
traction and pointed a lot of fingers
back at the company so that we can be in
the conversations that we need to be and
get asked to do more pitches or get
asked to do more work 2014 it was my
turn to contribute the challenging thing
with an interactive music video is that
you're not just making one linear video
you're kind of making multiple videos
and the way that I had done it just to
make a little bit more sense for me as
you build it out into three different
tracks there would be the middle track
which is the closest to reality so this
person is going through the world and it
feels the closest to the reality if you
move up a track and track a this is the
most aspirational one where he gets very
things get very dreamy things are very
soft and beautiful and warm and it feels
like this characters long-lost love is
actually there she's still there that
you can chase her and find her and then
track see the bottom is the dark
depressing version so all the colors
were a lot more muted or a lot more cool
and uninviting and as the viewer you get
to pick and go through the sequence do
you want to follow the dark path or the
right path ultimately you get to dictate
how the music video unfolds what story
happens based off of your interaction so
the idea behind this is that because you
have an interactive music video people
will watch it more than once people will
go and watch it the first time and then
try a different path the next time and a
different path the third time actually
did a TED talk about my experience
working on this project specifically and
you'll see me jumping in headfirst into
the deep end not knowing
what I'm knowing and coming out all
right coming out outside of my comfort
zone so I did this TED talk it was
called start before you're ready and
I'll link to that down below if you want
the full story of what happened on this
Coldplay Inc project if you guys don't
know I love video games I've been
playing video games since I was a young
boy and in my teenage years and even
into my college years some days I would
spend 10 hours playing video games like
that's how obsessed I was that's how
much I was into it and all of my life
has been a lot of video games and now
comes this opportunity where Xbox comes
along and this was a huge project so
here was this opportunity Eisenberg had
dropped this in our lap but they said
you know what we like your work we heard
you guys were good
we had never worked with him at this
point but we're putting you against
another company and this other company
was huge it was a company that I admired
for a very long time and I knew they had
over a hundred employees at the time
blind was only about 20 employees so
here it's a David and Goliath situation
where we're going against the heavy
hitters in the industry and here's me
pitching on this thing but the thing is
like I really love Xbox I spent most of
my time playing games on this platform
and so I had looked at the material I
looked at the brief and I started
working with my designers and we crafted
this treatment we submitted the
treatment but before I did on the last
page I wrote this very a heartfelt thank
you and what Xbox means to me and what
it means for me to be a gamer on this
platform and at the end of it I signed
it with my gamertag and a few days later
after submitting the pitch they said you
guys got this you guys won the pitch
and the reason why is because we could
tell that you guys are real gamers so
that passion all those many many years
of playing video games they were not a
waste they came together at this one
point and they served me in this moment
because I was feeling authentically
myself I was showing them that shoot I'm
a gamer I'm just not a creative director
only I'm a guy who grew up on video
games and specifically these characters
the characters that matter
so this premiered at e3 and got a really
good reception they're both from the
audience that was present and online we
won a couple of Clio awards from it and
that was fantastic and I remember
getting a message from the creative
director at the time and he said you
know this is some of the best work that
we've ever done Wow and from that point
forward we became their go-to studio for
everything Xbox so for the next four
years we did everything Xbox
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
since I became a creative director in
2011 as a 26 year old young guy being
not confident speaking to my team to
clients and understanding how to
articulate my thoughts to this moment
here where I'm fully confident in my
skills and able to put it all on screen
use all of the technical things that
I've learned all the design and
communication skills that have acquired
along the way to put out this and then
to have the public react to it the way
that they did
[Applause]
these videos got millions and millions
of views I think over ten millions views
man that was it that was me feeling like
wow I I did something significant as a
creative professional and this was a
nice moment nice time in my life to
celebrate and that was the that was 2017
and yeah I've been so privileged to have
such a good life such good experiences
and great people around me who have
supported me throughout this journey
from my parents and relatives who bought
me art supplies when I was growing up
teachers who to really push me and see
something inside me to tell me I could
do more and be more and to try harder to
having people challenge me and say is
this really your best because you can do
better and then having to go through the
ups and downs of wins and failures and
wins and failures and having the shame
of closing your company and kind of
falling short of all the expectations of
you all of these things have added up
and I'll tell you right now when I was
13 years old or even younger I would
have never imagined I'd be at this point
today I never could have pointed and
said that's where I'm gonna be that's
the job that I'm going to do I didn't
know what every step of their just
leading with curiosity I was just trying
to see what interests me and go deep
until it was dry and then I moved on to
the next thing and then the next thing
and I just kept developing I kept
collecting skills and knowledge meeting
people and just trying to give full
genuine efforts whenever I could so I
share this with all of you guys because
I want you to see that if you go back to
the very beginning you could see my
really bad self-portraits my
disproportionate human characters of my
classmates that I would draw it weren't
that great my Photoshop compositions
didn't make any sense I was
uncomfortable with a lot of mediums and
I was shy and introverted and many times
throughout my career I've been tested
and challenged
but I've been able to figure it out I'm
not any more special than you are
you have all of the same abilities that
I have if you just do the work if you
just show up and if you learn from
failures and just keep pushing forward I
think all of us have these great
opportunities in front of us where if
you look at the gap in front of you and
say this is the thing that's getting in
the way I want you to reframe it and say
this is an opportunity to close I can go
from where I'm at now to where I want to
be and if you can see that as an
opportunity instead of an obstacle and I
think you could really accomplish
anything throughout your creative life
throughout your creative career and for
me even though I'm saying this is the
past 20 years of Who I am I'm not done
I'm still a work in progress and I
haven't fully arrived yet in fact I've
been exploring a lot more personal work
in that past 2 or 3 years things that
are a lot more expressive that has
nothing to do with the client work that
I do but now I'm getting into this
introspective mode where I'm
understanding my thoughts and feelings
I'm starting to put it out there as
words and videos like this one and
pieces of art things that represent Who
I am
and I think I'm starting a new chapter
in my life that's all about artistic
expression and I'm very excited it's
very scary and you can ask anybody here
that I get a little insecure still I'm
not fully confident all the time because
I'm always in a new place in a new
territory I'm exploring new areas that I
don't know what the result is going to
be I don't know where I'm gonna end up
because of all these efforts I just know
that I have to do it I'm leading with
curiosity and I'm taking it as far as I
can until I hit a wall and then I move
on alright I hope you enjoyed this
series of the last 20 years of my
portfolio if you did learn something
from it let me know in the comments
below or share it with a friend by
sharing this video it really helps us
out as
the channel to know that you guys value
and like this stuff and that we should
do more like this if you have any
questions about your own creative career
or something that you saw in one of
these videos again leave us a comment
and I'll do my best to answer it if you
want to check out more of me look up
Matthew in Cena calm and you can follow
me on social at Matthew encina I'll see
you guys in the future alright okay yeah
alright the beastly recording yes it was